the weather that may have led to the
crash was also a factor for millions of
Americans who were traveling yesterday
there were a lot of us on the road there
were major flight delays and
cancellations for those trying to get
home after a Thanksgiving holiday Chris
Van Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
that's just outside Washington Chris Van
Cleave hello to you are the lines moving
there
well good morning the lines were very
long this morning but they are moving
and that is a good sign you know the
airlines knew this storm was coming they
planned for it for days and were able to
avoid the mass cancellations that we saw
over the summer still if you were flying
through D.C New York or Chicago you
likely left late we're talking about
thousands of delays it was a trip home
that required a lot of patience for a
lot of people
from highways and we've been in traffic
all day to side streets we have hit some
pretty dense patches of traffic there
was no Escape From The Crush of holiday
traffic for Millions trying to get back
home I'm always scared wind and fog
caused more than 6 000 flight delays but
fewer than 200 cancellations Nationwide
Sunday after what had been a fairly
smooth travel week I'm hoping we get out
of New York on time because of the
weather the flight was supposed to be at
6 50. we didn't take off until 11 30. uh
by the time we landed here it was close
to 2 A.M flights were halted in the New
York and DC areas for hours Sundays
airports expected to have their busiest
day since the pandemic planes are full
airports are kind of hectic packed
planes and the holidays brought out the
worst in some flyers while incidents of
disruptive passengers are down 80
percent this year after soaring during
the pandemic the Thanksgiving travel
period was marked by a number of
incidents
football star Odell Beckham Jr was
escorted off a flight by police in Miami
according to American Airlines he
refused to fasten his seat belt
Beckham's lawyer denies that account
a JetBlue flight from New York to Salt
Lake City was met by police after a
passenger allegedly threatened a woman
on board with a razor this follows an
incident earlier in the month where the
TSA missed a box cutter and a disruptive
passenger's bag TSA administrator David
pikoski insists air travel is safe
passengers shouldn't be concerned we
have literally all hands on deck when
that happens and try to figure out why
and then very quickly put measures in
place to prevent it from happening again
only a few flight delays on the boards
here at Reagan National Airport a lot of
people are flying today the airlines
expected it to be very busy we saw very
very long security lines and traffic
coming into the airport also felt like
Peak holiday time so at least one busy
day to come Nate
Chris thank you